man called the best move to help I feel
good a lot of guys who who rap we kind
of asked but you wouldn't so you'd be
like yeah just get better just keep
working
[Music]
open up the starter pack I'm gonna start
setting up my team now it's important to
get them to get the cards because you
really build a team that you want you
might want to play with LeBron you might
want to play with Coke basically just
having fun and putting together a team
that you always want to put together
basically I play what they give me
because I want to get my feet wet if I
could play with them and with some ass
then I read play with some real stars
I play a lot
I play a lot when I start playing 2K
this is around the time when I was just
like picking the colors of the team with
like I got the white team I started
paying attention after that started
watching basketball games for real now
playing the game helped me figure out
who the players was so like if I don't
know a player I just really just going
the game and just start playing with
random teams and figure it out
yeah D Rose one of my favorites for sure
because it kind of remind me of me in
real life being counted out Michael
Jordan still explaining to her just to
glitch to white Howard see if you use
this one you can shoot threes with him I
like the white but I want to get a can
so I'm going to the market try to find a
game this is the Super PAC I'll see what
I can get up out of here so I just got
uh Kevin Durant go personal friend of
mine too yeah I'm throwing a new KD card
in my lineup for sure
I didn't get the um King card
from the pack so I guess I got to put a
little few little strings see what I can
do it's cool I'll bust the ass and who I
got
cash
I'm gonna keep that to myself
cause I might need LeBron to play with
me tomorrow
I might need I need Jordan to send me
some shoes
get my starting to fight with me in it
it'd be Kevin Durant John Colby and Mike
we're gonna win anyway I Gotta Throw
Ellen Iverson in there too that's like
my favorite player overall I'll be the
sixth man I ain't tripping I actually
metal before he was in the club and I
was on the other side of the club
he was like
I'm like dang what's up bro but he came
over he was talking to somebody else so
I had to play it off like like I wasn't
doing nothing
yeah buddy I got really can't miss for
real
it might be down three I know what I'm
gonna do you know who's gonna do it
already I don't even need to talk
not at this game over with
let's see that get that game card I know
I got it though it was outbid it was a
sniper oh my God yeah somebody in this